are you doing four-way no Cruz and uber
yeah so what we've done at scale is
built the data platform for AI so AI is
really built on top of data and these
algorithms require billions and billions
of examples of labeled data to be able
to perform in a safe reliable way
so this 22 year old interviewed me for a
full-time position and rejected me just
kidding
he was 19 when he interviewed me and
rejected me that was three years ago and
that was a senior at Waterloo well in my
defense they never actually explicitly
rejected me they just go at me after the
interview I'll show you the emails later
let's take a look at their old website
this company used to be called scale API
and it wasn't focused only on labeling
training data they built an API for
human labor we're gonna go back to
August 2016
oh I don't think that's it
okay that's more like it so kind of like
TaskRabbit but with without the
in-person stuff so like phone surveys
transcription ecommerce tagging some
categorization outsourcing [ __ ] work
essentially now they only focus on
categorization aka labeling for model
training so refine the pitch work scale
was founded by Lucy Coe and Alexander
Wang if he does the name looks like a
startup anyways back then there were
only two co-founders and they were
looking to hire their first engineer so
I applied here's the email exchange we
had Lucy Kroll I actually matched with
her on tinder a year ago she didn't
respond to me but but then again my
opening message wasn't that great
so apparently my resume stood out
because I did a lot of different roles
so that's good as a startup we look for
someone who can wear many hats well
that's good they quickly hit me up with
a take home project oh [ __ ]
well I mean it's too late now the
project asked me to create post
endpoints for them so their customers
can send annotation box requests aka
send images and then we or CIO API will
have their contractors drop boxes around
whatever they want and then send them
back to the customers where they will
probably use it for some machine
learning model or something so this
project just focuses on this part and
the UI for the scale contractors to
actually draw the boxes actually I think
I still have the code for this let me
whip it out all right so here's what I
built so that the contractors can use to
draw boxes all right let's send us some
requests so here we see there's four
images or four requests I'm sending all
right and then we'll see this and here
you go so you could see now that you
have a few requests and here you see a
picture of a few cows and here it says
you have to annotate baby cow and big
cow and then the instructions it says
draw a box around each baby cow and big
cow so that's cool so I think it's
pretty simple you just you know draw
them baby cow baby cow baby cow oh no
that's not a baby cow so you know you
can exit out switch to big cow and then
annotate the big cow then you can also
reset it you could also say it's broken
I don't know if ever it's broken
and then here's also the urgency here
you could also sort by urgency if you
want so here you go you have urgency
sort by urgency sort by date you can
also click another one if you don't want
to do this one right now yeah I think
that's pretty much it so let me just
annotate this baby cow baby cow
baby cow and then mama cow this will be
saved in the database and sent to the
customer and the customer receive will
receive these things and then you just
submit and then you submit it and then
here's another example I think this is a
picture of a k-pop group called
notes okay I know it's like pink okay I
know it's black pink so here it says
draw a box around the best black pink
member and then the objects is like my
bias okay um let's see okay
[Music]
okay and then oh [ __ ] are you serious
all right so I think you get the point
and they also told me to use the mean
stack if I can but to be honest I wasn't
much of a front-end guy so I ended up
using the men stack you know very
patriarchy of me I had some angular but
it was clear that I wasn't really using
the framework right but I mean they said
they loved it though but I have a
feeling they didn't look at the source
code until later on when they goes in me
so no hard feelings though i mean i i'd
ghost myself too i would have been a
trash employee what's poppin guy here's
a day in the life of an early start
employee so here's me coding right now
so they invited me for an interview and
alexander the CEO interviewed me we just
chatted and then he asked me an
algorithm question the question was fine
median in the data stream question he
had to give me a hint for me to solve it
so that probably didn't help my chances
and unfortunately he didn't respond to
me after the interview and then as you
can see here's my last desperate attempt
after a month oh no actually actually
that was my last attempt
you